a demise research conference that we are
trying over time to return to um
in person
as you know we have different
presentations um
from
either visiting scholars or faculty or
students fellows and we also have um
presentations related to our
diversity equity inclusion and
anti-racism committee and that is uh
what today's presentation is going to
focus on and it's going to be given by
one of our
informatics fellows um chengdu zhang who
most of you
know
and i'm going to have a little cheat
sheet here so i can
talk a little bit about his background
um actually did you went to peking union
medical college
for medical school yeah um we had a
student um some of you may remember tian
jinping in in the mid 2000s who was from
pumc
and um she actually invited me to visit
and back by about 10 years ago i was
able to visit there so i think that was
before maybe before you were in medical
school anyways
we won't dwell on that um but anyways um
changda is a clinical informatics fellow
as most of you know and he um
is
after his um
medical school
came to the u.s and did a residency in
internal medicine at beaumont health and
then he uh pursued a fellowship in
critical care medicine here at ohsu and
always had an interest in informatics
and somehow i think through vishnu and
jeff gold
got connected with us and now has joined
our fellowship program and he is in our
master's program i think yes yes so he's
[Music]
doing
all kinds of great and interesting
things around data science and
i know from his interactions with the
committee that he's very interested in a
lot of these some
diversity and equity issues
and um he is
going to talk to us today really both
present the article and hopefully lead
some discussion to the extent we can
have discussion in this
um
format while we're still working all
this out on
our racial bias that gets documented in
the electronic health record and i think
those of us who have clinical
backgrounds know that this has always
been an issue the comments that get
written into medical records and with
the heightened awareness of this problem
um
various research studies have attempted
to document it and so he'll talk about
that and um i'll let him lead the
discussion i'm just the moderator uh
paul gorman who's the chair of the
committee would have been the moderator
today but uh paul is out for a few weeks
on medical leave um so um i will serve
as the moderator but it's really changed
who's going to leave the discussion
today so we will turn it over to him
two
all right um
can
can everybody see my slice
yes and this is
the right size now the presenter view
right
they look good to me yes yes okay
all right thank you and uh
yeah thank you dr perch for introducing
me and
today
i am gonna present this article that is
published in uh february uh of this year
and uh uh from chicago and they are
talking about uh uh the documentation by
a racial bias in the election and health
records
and uh
my name is chonda again i'm a first year
informatica fellow um
here's the structure of my of today's
presentation
the i'm gonna
start by talking about the background of
this article and then uh the methods
results and then i'll put in some
discussions both from the authors and
also from myself my thoughts regarding
this uh
negative
descriptors about patients in the ehr
the main research question in this
article is
is this one does the provider's use of
negative patient descriptors vary by
patient's race or ethnicity
and i i
further specified this question into
this uh
possible causal diagram and then then on
the left side we have the racial race
and ethnicity and the the article here
is trying to investigate the association
and hopefully maybe uh
shine some lights on this potential
causal relationship between
race and the negative patient
descriptors
so this is the main focus of this
article
um so the author said there there hasn't
been any quantitative approach in terms
of analyzing
how
how the difference in the negative
descriptors in actual real world ehr
between different ethnic groups
here is the the here the the the causal
diagram i'm drawing here
[Music]
is the upper part is the thing that we
already know and then the bottom part is
that this article is trying to
investigate
so we know a few things about
race and ethnicity in health care
we know it may cause maybe leads to
racial discrimination and implicit bias
and
such bias can lead to worse
communication between the patients and
healthcare providers and can cause worse
compliance from the patient and both
those two factors can come back and
reinforce the discrimination and bias
and ultimately leads to delayed care or
less care or worse care for the patient
and on the right side there hasn't been
much studies about the negative
descriptors
but uh
once that is published recently they did
mention uh that uh
for
for providers if they are shown
um about those negative descriptors
before seeing the patients they may pose
a negative perception about the patient
and that negative perception may
ultimately lead to the delay here or
less care
for example in the case of pain
management if the
provider saw that the patient have
some documented
like non-compliance or or possible drug
seeking
behavior and then there
the provider tends to formulate a
less aggressive pain
regimen for this patient
so uh so
here's what we know and the article is
going to talk a few focus on the bottom
part of this causal diagram here
the hypothesis in this article is that
they think
that the nodes in the ehr with
stigmatizing language may be
disproportionately
applied to racially minoritized patients
and how they go about to approve them so
next few slides i'm going to talk about
their methodology
the first of all the data source the
data all comes from comes from
actually a copenhagen data mart
there's a potential problem here with
using the covenant gene data mart
because all the patients have some
relationship with kobe 19 and which is
not
which which means that this data data
science is not created solely for the
purpose of this research
there may be some selection bias i'm
going to talk about later
but uh but the author said the their
their data sets is pretty complete so
that they want to use this uh reuse this
copy 19 data mark for their research
purposes
um and in total they got about 18 000
patients
and the data was they were able to track
back to
january 1st and 9th 2019 and they are
also uh and they collected the data
until uh october 1st 2020
at least
so every patient needs to have some sort
of notes in there
so that the author can
do some analysis
so they require that at least the one
history of physical should be documented
on each patient
in order for the patient to be qualified
for their study and lastly their one of
the exclusion criteria is that they
excluded everyone with dementia which is
the condition
commonly associated with the negative
descriptors in the ehr and does not
necessarily have any racial
racial specific distribution
so they excluded this condition because
they thought this might be a confounder
the next step is actually
building a
natural language processing
mechanism
for them
for
so that they can use this
automatic program to read through all of
the notes that they reported from the
patient
charts
the first step of building this natural
language processing uh
mechanism is
identify all of those keywords that may
be associated with uh
with an active descriptor
the the way that author did they search
for the term of difficult patients and
all of the keywords that may be
similarly associated with them and here
i listed the
the terms that they use in total they
have 15 of them
for example they have non-pleasant
non-cooperative and historical defensive
non-compliant or
confrontational or
non-adherent angry challenging
exaggerate
refuse resist
aggressive combative so those are the
key words that
that the author is gonna gonna use
to retrieve all the sentences that
contains those keywords
and then the next step is it's more
involved
in machine learning and they have to
build a algorithm that they can that can
automatically identify the meaning the
actual meaning of the extracted
sentences
for example a sentence
may say that this patient has support is
has been poorly compliant so this is a
confirmed
negative descriptor for this patient
and then the author will manually come
and annotate this sentence as negative
descriptor
and they want to uh they won't have this
mechanism being nlp mechanism being able
to differentiate negative and positive
so for example if the sentence is
actually telling the
reader that the patient is actually
being compliant and the author will mark
it as positive and trying to teach this
nlp mechanism that
we are
that we are learned uh that we are
actually seeing an opposite of negative
which is a positive
and then there is a third category uh
of uh of sentences those sentences is
not actually describing the patients
themselves
they may be describing describing an
object or something or someone else for
example
the word compliant can be used to
describe balloon so this is how they
categorize those out of context
um
this steps of manually annotating the
sentences are critical in building this
model
in terms of
to help the author scale up their
analysis so in the first stage they
annotated about 6
800
sentences and used them to view the
machine learning model and the two
thirds of what the in the training set
and one third of them comes through the
testing set
they claim that their model had a f1
score of
0.935 and they said it's a pretty uh
it's almost perfect model in terms of
differentiating those
sentences with categorizing them as a
negative descriptor which is the the
thing that we're looking for today so uh
they built this model and then they are
going to use this model to
look into all of this 18 000 patients
and then the last step is just the
statistical analysis which is the easier
part
[Music]
they
they basically use the multivariate
logistic regression trying to figure out
the uh the association between the as
research ethnicity and the presence of
negative patient descriptors in the
patient's note
so
before building this whole multivariate
like this regression model
usually is a common practice and we want
to
make sure that all the confounders are
being controlled
so i put a question mark here the
authors they listed all of this
confounders and they put them into their
model i think language is one of them it
makes sense they can affect the patient
risk and also it's affecting the
patient's negative descriptor but i'm
not sure about the rest of them six
factors listed here
maybe their confounding factor maybe
they're just some mediators so the
author
anyway
they included all of these factors such
as insurance providers encounter
location
or the
patient medical complexity encounter
length positive covariating tests and
timing of economy those factors i'm not
sure they are confounding factors but
the author included them anyway
the
luckily the author did listed both the
unadjusted and then adjusted
ours ratio for
for the recent ethnicity so we're gonna
so we're gonna see in the results it's
actually i think the
the practice of uh statistical analysis
is uh
is fair here
uh we're gonna let's so let's so now
let's the next step let's look at the
actual results of this article
this is table one
the
this table one basically is a
descriptive analysis that showed up
that showed how the negative
negative descriptors are presenting
across different
groups of the patient
in total they have
all among all of their patients being
analyzed 8.2 percent of patients had one
or more negative descriptors in their
history of physical notes in their ehr
and the the focus of our study
uh here today is mostly on the race
racial bias so here you can see the the
black patients account for about sixty
percent of their total patient
population
and then uh those sixty percent of
patients actually accounts for
almost eighty percent of the negative
descriptor
from this uh
descriptive analysis we see there might
be association whether uh whether the
association is significant or not we're
going to move to the next table which is
the major results of this paper they uh
they basically used both the univariate
and multivariate logistic regression
proved that
race
black is being associated with uh
with having an active descriptors in
their ehr
so
they have odds ratio 2.84 in the
unadjusted hours ratio for adjusted
hours ratio they have out of 2.54 with a
95 percent confidence interval of 1.99
to 3.24
the next step the author did do two more
sensitivity testing uh trying to see
prove that if that's the
that's a valid observation from their
data
the first step the author want to
exclude further patients not just a
patient with dementia they exclude
patients with delirium substance use and
mental behavior diagnosis and after
excluding all of those patients the
black is still an independent
association has the independent
association with negative descriptors
with the um house racial 2.88 and 95
confidence interval 2.03 to 4.11
um
the next sensitivity testing they did is
look at the actual number of
negative descriptors in each patient
actually per 100 patients and compare
this between black and white patients
and they saw that black waste was
associated with 5.6 more
negative notes
per 100 patients
compared with white waste
so
let's move on so we're done with the
results of this paper oh let's let's
move on to the discussion
first the discussion that's
that's putting by the authors
one of the major i think limitations in
this study is actually the
the selection bias that i mentioned
earlier
i think they the fact that they use the
kobe 19 datasets is not actually ideal
one of the
one of the reason is that we look at the
previous slides on the last line
and they did analyze the timing of the
encounter
after march 1st 2020 versus before march
1st 2020 and they saw that uh there's an
association of decreasing use of
negative descriptors after march 1st
2020
um
and the author uh putting some
hypothetical explanation maybe the
providers
after this uh copenhagen pandemic they
are putting more ppe and patients are
being on
in isolation they're having less
interaction uh person-to-person
interaction with the patient and uh
therefore the they're they're gonna put
in less negative descriptors
uh so that that's a possibility
so uh so anyway copenhagen may be
associated
is affecting our
results here so it's it's not the it's
not the ideal data size for us to use to
analyze the negative descriptors in
patients and trying to figure out the
ratio bias uh in that
in that situation so i i think the data
set selection uh is not ideal
um and the author did argue that after
april 1st 2020 everyone in the inpatient
and ed setting
basically everyone had a screening test
for carbon 19 so
that means all of those patients in ed
and inpatient after april 1st
are
are actually included so no matter
whether they have any association with
cognition or not so they are included in
status size but the the problematic for
but there is still problem for the
outpatient data and there's still
problems for data before april first
that's the
that's the challenging uh the most of
the most significant limitations i see
for this article
and of course this is the single center
study
it's
it doesn't have too much racial uh
representation
of
of other
other races other than black and white
and this is also a cross-sectional study
and we do not know we cannot know about
the actual facts of natural negative
descriptors on the patient outcomes
because it's still cross-sectional
so those are the limitations i talked
about and we all saw the results and i
think uh uh just by
looking at the results as the the
results is pretty solid and we are being
faced with some sort of uh
racial bias in the in our ehr and the
question here
that i thought about is what can we do
can we do something
now as an information to help
uh minimize those bias
so uh
so why why why is there a bias just
based on the race and economy i think
most of them comes from stereotype
um is there a way for us
to implement something changes in the
ehr to help minimizing uh
stereotyping
one one way that i saw on the uh
that a group of computer engineering
from india is
trying to do for facebook
is they
they implement this app
that that is intentionally sharing
inspiring stories about certain
race ethnicity or gender groups
so that
so that those stories are
are aimed to break the stereotype
and
and
remind people that everyone
should be should be different and you
should approach
someone personally before jetting them
based on their
uh
their like race or gender uh then
stereotyping them
so i propose so i have i have several
thoughts about what we can do here
so first of all i'm thinking about how
to make the ehr more personally
and we
in the past few years we saw the efforts
of putting the actual patient photo in
the ehr which i think is a good effect
for our providers
psychologically and i think uh i think
we can do more
and
it's it's always better to know about
our patients personally rather than uh
leave those questions for the provider
to judge their patients based on their
uh their stereotype
uh maybe we can connect
the ehr with my chart and let the
patient put in some
uh brief introduction about themselves
uh so that we we know that everyone is
different
for me as the
creative care provider every morning i
go to the icu i quickly walk walk
through the unit and see if the
uh and sees everyone around stable and
at that time when i'm standing on the
hallway just looking at everyone
everyone looks the same they're all
having some sedation got intubated
having some shocky physiology but once
you start talking with the patient's
nurse you walk into the patient's room
and sometimes you can see the patient's
their family photos and the picture
taken when they were healthy so it's uh
it has a different effect on on me
and
you start to realize that everyone is
different they have their own needs and
uh and the provider the provider you
should
be professional and stop being like
and
stop being using any like stereotyping
language in your notes
the second
suggestion that i have here is maybe we
can implement some more
uh
more uh
like
360 degree evaluation for the patient
especially in the inpatient side
uh the way that we are right now
collecting uh
like negative or positive descriptors
from the notes is actually by just
reading the note from the emitting
physician or the definition just one
note but i think that's unfair for the
patient
so first of all the patients come to the
hospital they may have different uh
illness they just have different
phytophysiology so that's a pat
for sure it's impacting their mood
and will impacting their interaction
with the providers
and the second way certain patients may
have like
better or different interaction with
certain ethnic groups of providers
so uh i think the better way to
actually putting the evaluation about
patient behavior
is in the ehr we can include a section
that uses nlp
techniques
to pulling all the negative and positive
descriptors in the past for this patient
so that the provider once they saw this
section they have a general overview of
the patient's behavior in the past not
just from the admitting physicians
windows
that way
things to be more fair for the patient
and you can see the whole picture of the
patient in the past
and then thirdly i think
one of the things that we can make
changes in the year chart maybe put some
explanations beside the negative
descriptors and for example if the note
is saying that this patient is being
uncompliant
and then our ehr can
goes into the previous met information
and retrieve relevant medication and
diagnosis that may explain the patient's
behavior for example someone say this
patient is being non-compliant
and how about we go into the year trying
to see if the patient actually had
have have been diagnosed with dementia
and
in that way provider once they see that
patients being uncompliant they also
understand that the patient is just
physically incapable of being compliant
to to their own healthcare
so uh that's all
that's all the my three thoughts
suggestions
so uh so based on the results and
of this article and anyone has any
questions and i would like to open for
like open discussion
about uh for this
this article
thank you great thank you
make sure you repeat
oh yeah
and uh
yeah the good question the uh the
question here is why
uh there's such a big
effects of marital status with negative
descriptors here
here but you can see the results part is
showing that marital status is actually
of being not married has uh imposed a
significant risk of having negative
descriptors both in the unadjusted
racial and digestive ratio so this is a
solid observation and the author did
mention that in the uh in their
in their discussion part that they think
this the the data is is real and they
think uh there isn't association but
they don't specify why
um so uh so um yeah and and i don't
think the data here in the article is
enough to ask the question why there is
association we are observing
um
yeah and regarding the question for race
and ethnicity no they did not look into
whether certain races less likely to be
married or not
besides that
yeah so the question is if we are
uh if we use a different data sets maybe
not just uh for clovid um
but uh maybe a better data sets are
representing actual patients and uh are
we
are we gonna see a uh stronger uh
association between uh between race and
the negative descriptors
uh
uh
i don't know it actually depends um uh
it actually depends on what happens
um
in this data sets and then after for
example after march 1st are are we are
we observing
more admission of black patients versus
white patients
and then in that case
since those patients are getting less
negative descriptors and i suppose that
we if we use a different data sets we're
going to observe even more
disparity
however
i'm not sure if that's the case and
maybe
they are
maybe it's the opposite case and they
are just emitting more white patients
and in that case then we're going to see
less
so uh yeah the the answer is that we
don't know yet
i want to share your slides of some chat
traffic yeah
this is chris my question in the chat is
about the diagram that's early on in
your slides so i don't know if it would
help to show that causal pathways
diagram again when you come to um
answering the question if you'd like
sure uh
actually let me figure out
uh
let me first pull up my chat i haven't
seen the chat
keep
yet
[Music]
yeah
that's all i see here oh here oh yeah oh
it says chad to the right
i guess for you become this
again another one yeah this one yeah
okay
yep are you are you on a different
screen yeah i'm in a different scene
here
let's let me just stop sharing
okay
that's better
uh
so questions
uh
the question
let me show the diagram here
feel free to take the other questions if
those are easier for yeah perfect
so we have the diagram here yes perfect
i was curious i i know you talked a lot
about this data set maybe not being the
data set that you would hope for for
this question
i thought there might be um a direct
line from worse compliance to negative
patient descriptors that didn't come
through a pathway of
care or perception
but just
comments about you know negative
comments about the patient
about compliant you know that compliance
would lead to that directly without
going through the other arms of the
pathway
and i wondered with the data that you
have in that study
with that journal club would they have
been able to
assess
whether it goes through a pathway of
delayed care or less care or if it's
more direct in the sense of the way you
presented their findings to us it seemed
like you could go directly from bad
compliance to
the negative descriptors without maybe
going through the care pathway and and
what are your thoughts on that i realize
it's not your data but i was curious
from what you saw yeah thank you
uh yeah um
so are you asking about different data
sets
that
we have access to
i think i'm just asking the way they
studied the question
it seemed like they kind of went
directly from worse compliance on this
diagram to negative patient
descriptors and they didn't have to go
through those arrows of compliance
equals delayed care less care delayed
care leads to negative perception
negative perception leads to negative
descriptors they kind of in my way of
understanding your presentation of their
work they kind of
went straight from worse compliance with
an arrow down to negative patient
descriptors and i didn't know if that
was just me
missing a step or two in what they had
presented or if you felt like maybe they
were drawing that line directly without
their pathway
yeah i i think they're uh theoretically
there should be a line from uh from this
words compliance to the negative patient
descriptors and
um but all of those factors looks uh
that
they're gonna inter interact with
each other i think negative perception
can also leads to
worse compliance and worse compliance
can feedback and reinforce an active
perception here
this is a very complex network here
where we're looking at
the
i don't think the data itself is being a
retrospective for cross-sectional data
it's gonna show us much about the causal
diagram here but the the only thing
they're trying to prove is the
association whether it exists here in
the in the bottom here
this one uh
in order to do some more uh more uh
subtle analysis on the
uh on those on this causal diagram it's
uh it's gonna be challenging
and i uh yeah
um and i
i think there may be ways of analyzing
it
but i'm not uh not not an expert in that
of that field
thank you that was very helpful
articles is on this topic that were
published pretty close to one another
um
was
what made you choose this one over the
other one
uh actually i'm not aware of this uh the
other drama article it's a is it a
the question sorry the question is why
i'm choosing this article there seems to
be another
uh
article published in drama and
i thought do you mind uh describe that
article yeah so this article from jama
is also examining sigma titanium
language and the electronic health
record and found similar
association
but it also
kind of
address some of your data set issues so
like some of all admissions
uh
related to only one single diagnosis
and it also looked at
um
author factors so you know who wrote
movement
yeah okay so uh so in summary the
dodgers mentioned that this jam article
uh has maybe had a better data sets and
uh to represent uh to to answer the
research question and he also addresses
the
the the rays of the of the provider who
are documenting the
the notes
actually i'm seeing a
question from
uh homer about uh
about the race of providers um in this
in this in this article so in in the one
that i'm presenting today they did not
mention about any provider's race uh
that's it's affecting the patient's
uh uh their documentation so i think
they're uh definitely that article uh
that mentioned in general is
seems to be uh sounds to be a
better quality article
and uh
and i uh the reason i choose this one i
think it's interesting and
um it's more uh and it's uh it combines
the the like nlp
um techniques and machine learning and
their own
analysis and uh
if i
if i read the drama article maybe that's
a this is a good one to present uh side
to side and to give up give people a
better
view about this
topic
the next question i have is from uh
from benjamin
is the
key
he wonders if they should have
controlled for the number of notes per
patient or at least
for it and
association
that's a that's a good question
whether they should control for the
notes
the number of notes for the patient
they
they did do an interesting analysis that
did i mentioned in their uh
the sensitivity analysis and trying to
see how many
negative notes that each patient 100 per
100 patients have uh in their group
uh
and they kind of imply that the the more
notes you have
the the
the more negative like
the the the more negative that that you
got for the other for
the
description from your providers
um and i'm not not sure about that maybe
so there are right now there are a lot
of copy pasting of the notes uh
and
a view
you have maybe one provider putting
concerns about patients being
non-compliant and other providers may
just copy and paste and you end up with
multiple notes
so that's i think that's also part of
the reason the author focused only on
whether or not a patient had a negative
descriptor
rather than a number of notes
yeah that's uh that's my answer i i i
think there
there is there may be value to prove
your uh major results in terms of
analyzing number of notes but uh
are there's also limitations in doing
that analysis
and uh and then the other question also
would like to have uh have seen an
evaluation of the demographic data uh
data quality
by the authors uh
because this data in ehr is often
inaccurate uh that's uh that's uh that's
exactly uh the point actually i am in
this uh i am in our ohsu's disparity
dashboard and we have been trying to
build some uh
some data elements that can better
represent patients
race and ethnicity group and
it seems like there is a lot of
challenging in building this
just this
single data element
and
and think about that the patients can
define their own race and ethnicity
they may present as one race
for today and then they decide to change
it for the future and this it becomes a
complex um data storage issue
uh for the future so i i think
uh i think that's the challenging part
and the
author did not mention about the quality
of data source
and uh
and
and i i think
it's it's fair to assume that they their
their data elements is not better than
the average
epic
data elements that we have available
right now
and then next question
is it possible that the associations are
picking up on real disparities and not
negative stereotyping
for example a black patient may very
well be less compliant or more
argumentative because the treatment plan
will cause an economic economic hardship
loss of wages for networking
the variables including included in the
analysis suggested that the variables
that could be uh potential uh practices
for economic status have a strong
relationship that's so uh that's uh yeah
that's the question i think that's
that's a solid point uh we do see
let me let me
let me see my own slide i'm maybe gonna
read off the
the main results here so
uh it seems that uh for there is a
difference in terms of patient insurance
providers and if you are on medicaid and
medicare you do have a higher odds of
getting a negative descriptor
and if the patient is on
and then the patient is having uh more
cause uh higher calcium uh comorbidity
index which like clinical medical
complexity they also tends to have a
more negative descriptors
so
so that i think i think this is a fair
question is a good point um
and
to think about educating providers one
part
and there might actually be some
challenging thing in helping those
patients
uh because they are already suffering
from unstable financial situations
um
so that's uh
so i think that might be another way to
address the the current problem that we
are
not noticing in this article
now
good question thank you
and then lastly we have uh
vishnu a question
as chondan noted i also wonder about how
the pervasive copy plus pasting that
exists in the workflow today
may propagate biases in charting from
one provider to another uh yeah i
i think that's
that is definitely affecting our
documentation for the patient
change i just wanted to make a comment
one
very good presentation and one thing i
really liked was that you brought out
some next steps which the authors did
not seem to do
um
i got a sense from the conclusion
that
they made a conclusion
but they didn't really
[Music]
say well
we found this out
what are we going to do about it
that was just my sense of it
yeah
and i don't know
you know because i come from the
university of chicago i kind of know
they were looking at it in a theoretical
way
okay which is they do but um but i
thought what you were doing too is that
there are ways that we can
change how we're doing this you know
that kind of thing so that's the way i
say that
yeah
okay
thanks catherine
and
um
yeah yeah i think there are
definitely multiple ways and the patient
needs support our provider needs support
and
and better education as well um
so i i put in some preliminary
recommendations uh from implementation
standpoints and
i i do see this going to be a team
efforts
multi multidisciplinary both the
patients primary care providers and
patients
primary team and as well as the
social work and team that can we can
work work together better supporting
patients with
racial minority groups
okay let's have a and you have a
question yeah questions actually related
but
um
again she was asking about solutions and
i was like
yeah yeah yeah
trivia
yeah i'll try to repeat your question so
are you asking us like we
um
is there any sort of like data can be
helpful for us to explore and find out
um or point out point out a way for us
to address this observe the problems
here
yeah so uh
in the data itself
i think if you look into more uh more
details like like we just did we find
out that
um some patients with certain insurance
providers indicating maybe a a lower
socio-economical status is having
trouble
and
and that
that can shine some light and you can
see some association
um that is
that is causing the problem and
really for this cross-sectional
retrospective study you can't really
tell if it's a causal relationship or
it's or if it is just a
simple association and we already have
such a complex
causal diagram here to analyze
and i i think if you look um
if you do some like subtle analysis on
the subgroups of patients you may see
something
but it's it's not going to be definitive
and
it's not going to tell you for sure that
this is a problem
um again this is a it's going to be a
multifactorial
and it's going to be a big project
to address but but i think that i
believe that
if you look into the details of the the
data nuances of this data and you should
be able to find some of them
um
yeah
thanks
i actually thought maybe i would i it's
really more of a comment than a question
i thought i would just come up here so
you didn't have to repeat it but
you know so what one
issue um this is bill i don't know
people can see me or not but they
probably recognize my voice um one issue
um
one thing that this study
i i guess because i'm always thinking
about well you know what can we do with
ehr data you know all these great things
we want to do with it
research
quality measurement etc
and
i think these findings and also the the
other paper that daw refers to you know
are kind of a window
into the um
um
you know some of the issues with the ehr
we sometimes tend to think that you know
the data in the ehr is almost sacrosanct
you know that it's this
absolutely medically objective view of
patients and you know we're going to do
other things with this data we're going
to apply machine learning algorithms to
it and so forth and so i think um
another
realization and i'm actually trying to
figure out how to turn this into a
question
but you know
you know how do we um how do we improve
this part of the data in the ehr so that
our
machine learning and other algorithms
are not led astray by other biases and
not not only these biases but maybe
there's other biases in the record as
well
that um will undermine you know what we
hope to do with being able to predict
things and
uh you know give people good advice and
so forth
i don't know if there's a question there
but
i don't know if you or anyone else has
any comments
that's a good point
okay are there any more
we're just about at time is there any
more comments in the chat i don't know
that i can see the chat
we will hopefully
make this
it's going to be a learning experience
to figure out how to do these in a
hybrid way
yeah
yeah
no more no more comments in the chat
okay well um this was a very um
interesting a very nice presentation and
interesting uh discussion around it um i
think that there are many issues that we
as informaticians
need to think about so um
thank you changda and we'll see everyone
at the conference next week
thank you
thank you